Thanks so Ryan said he was going to give
a whiteboard talk so he inspired me if
theis I'm just kind of put forward with
slides so I just gonna write on the
board see how Joe also I'm super jet
lagged it's like oh it's good I stupidly
took United and was the way for six
hours and and then my bag took an hour
to come out of the back three mornings
listen I usually wake up about 4:30
Eastern and so it's kind of threw me off
of it ok so I want to scale up Bayesian
inference so what the hell does that
mean
so so usually so you're doing Bayesian
inference and so you have some sort of
likelihood function of Y given theta ok
so this is your your data and this is
your parameter unknowns okay and so um
so what what usually people do I think
when data really big high dimensional or
the sample size is large you tend to in
modern days kind of just focus on
optimization and so most of the
literature is based on kind of getting a
good estimate of theta hat maybe theta
is enormous ly high dimensional and so
it could be very very big huge matrix or
tensor or function and we're trying to
efficiently get theta hat even though
the sample size is huge and the
dimension is huge but in the
applications I care about we really
super care about uncertainty
quantification because we want to do
scientific inferences and so we did run
a study and we have limited number of
patients and the variables we collect on
the patients and the unknown things we
care about and doing scientific
inferences are really high dimensional
and so you can't really do this kind of
deep learning thing or something like
that or just do point optimization
because uncertainty is everything okay
there's a huge amount of uncertainty and
you have to quantify it well or your
scientific inferences are going to be
totally messed up the literature will be
full of false positives false negatives
and errors okay we don't care about just
a black box for doing pattern
classification we care about scientific
inferences so maybe this is data on
brain structure from different humans
and you want to know how brain structure
is related to phenotypes like depression
or autism
okay or maybe these are genomic data and
these status over here are parameters
characterizing which genes are related
to some particular disease of interest
okay so these are really high
dimensional the sample size might not be
that huge colors would yes okay it's
funny because I think that like machine
learning has been taken over by deep
learning
partly because everyone in machine
learning most differently everyone is
focused on these kind of industry
problems these industry pipe problems
where you have huge sample sizes huge
amounts of labeled data so if you have a
small sample size not met much training
data not many labeled data and the
dimension is big and you don't have some
very very intricately carefully
structured data like an image but you
have data where which has an unknown
structure inside to mention 'el then
these deep learning methods are not
designed for that type of setting and I
think that it's been really a shame that
everyone is kind of shifted their focus
to the setting where you're almost
always industry applications and not so
much science you know like biomedical
science or science beyond these kind of
cases where you're trying to identify
what's in an image or the audio
classification or industry type problems
and you can you can disagree with that
if you want but I really haven't it's
been overhyped the deep learning in the
set setting of scientific inferences
where we almost always in the scientific
applications I have you have limited
data the data tend to be high
dimensional and we have a lot of
uncertainty and we don't want a black
box for prediction we want to understand
the structure okay and so I'd like to
have a call from machine learning people
in general to work on these problems
more if we do some sort of sparse
structure learning and you get a point
estimate of that structure that's about
useless because that structure might not
be representing the true science and
then you're like reading tea leaves and
propagating false positives in the
literature which is not not good and so
that's one reason that I not
philosophically necessarily but just as
a practical matter it tend to focus on
Bayesian type of approaches because it
provides a convenient paradigm for
characterizing uncertainties okay not
perfect there's problems and it would be
wonderful for people to be thinking and
kind of stepping back and thinking
philosophically about how to solve some
of these problems like robustness to the
model and things like that okay but
anyway so I'm talking about a little bit
about the kind of what can we do well
we're going to have a likelihood
parameters parameterizing like lead
function and the likely to the data
we're doing a Bayesian approach we're
also going to have a prior PI of theta
some probability distribution on our
unknown parameters okay now and then
your from that you're going to get a
posterior distribution and so that's PI
of theta of Y given theta divided by
what's a normalizing constant which is
the marginal likelihood okay all this L
of Y and so usually so this guy is kind
of characterizing uncertainty and so you
could think well here's their parameter
space theta and so this is a probability
distribution over this parameter space
you know those parameters could be which
subset of the variables are important in
predicting depression from brain
structure could be other things as well
okay and so we have some generic
posterior distribution and so we can in
general do inferences this way
quantifying uncertainty and what happens
in high dimensional problems is a couple
of things so the one thing is that if if
this parameter space is large then this
integral is very high dimensional okay
and this can be very difficult to
analytically approximate and so Dave
Dave lies done amazing things with
variational methods trying to get some
type of approximation to this posterior
distribution based on some sort of
variation approximations but often we
don't know how well those are going to
do they might do well in machine
learning contexts or industry
applications perhaps not so well in
scientific applications where we really
care about quantifying uncertainty
accurately okay and so if we have this
posterior distribution that's going to
be high dimensional we have this
difficult integral it's usually not in
an enclosed analytic form and we might
also have have difficulty evaluating it
because
computationally expensive okay and so
what do people usually do in the setting
the kind of tools that have been around
for a while are you have Markov chain
Monte Carlo okay I'm Sam Cyr Markov
chain Monte Carlo and so the game in
market Markov chain Monte Carlo which is
the introduction of these methods is
what really caused Bayesian methods to
kind of take off in general is that we
can bypass having to calculate this
integral in the denominator and we can
we can define some iterative sampling
algorithm where the samples converged to
stationary distribution which is this
joint posterior distribution and then
based on those samples we can do our
inferences okay and so the game is we
define some sort of Markov chain on
theta T's we interval sample these data
T's and they're going to converge to
stationary distribution which is this
joy posterior distribution okay
it's kind of revolutionized use of
Bayesian methods these MCMC algorithms
and there's a whole set of different
algorithms ryan adams is one of like
they're really kind of guru and
discovering new types of algorithms for
difficult problems like gaussian
processes and non / metrics okay and so
so what do we do though so if we have
air in a small dimensional problem that
state is not that high dimensional then
this is very well developed very general
MCMC algorithms but there are some
problems that arise in big and high
dimensional data so in big and high
dimensional data dimensional data we
have some problems okay so we might have
you know computational bottlenecks per
iteration bottlenecks per iteration
okay so bevery so we're going to define
a Markov transition kernel it might be a
gift sampler you would sample for me to
the full conditional distributions and
so if you had a parameter vector theta
one through state of P you might sample
theta one given the other Thetas fix
from their full conditional distribution
and then cycle through and that that
would be defining your Markov transition
colonel in the Markov chain and then you
keep doing that okay or in general the
troppo tastings algorithms you would
instead to find a proposal and accept or
reject whenever you're doing that you in
general need to to evaluate the
likeliest function
you might need to calculate gradients
you often have to invert matrices that
might be have computational bottlenecks
that's like order n cubed in the sample
size and so you're going to get you know
per iteration iteration slowdowns okay
you're also going to get problems with
what's called mixing mixing rate
problems so what we want to do in Markov
chain Monte Carlo is where we're
sampling the state of T's and so we'd
like to sample the state at the t's in a
way so that they converge really quickly
to close to the stationary distribution
which is the posterior distribution and
we'd like them to mix really well and so
in an ideal world we could even generate
independent samples from the posterior
distribution but in reality they're
going to be Auto correlated and so if
they're very Auto correlated that would
mean that the Markov chain is slow
mixing and you're going to have to
calculate collect a lot of samples maybe
10,000 samples instead of 100 samples to
get the same Monte Carlo error and some
statistical estimator we care about so
one of those might be you know for
example a confidence interval or
credible interval characterizing on
third certainty and one of the
parameters state of one or you can do it
really for any any functional of the
parameters so you can calculate a point
estimate a poster mean and a 95%
interval okay so we have these two
bottlenecks and so what we'd like to do
what we're doing in a we have a NSF
Foundation is a big data proposal right
now and I've been working with a group
of postdocs and students and a professor
in the math department on kind of trying
to study the properties of MCMC
algorithms and develop new algorithms to
solve these bottlenecks okay and so
because I think that we can actually
scale MCMC up to two really quite big
problems and and be competitive with
things like variational algorithms
particularly using parallel processing
okay and so so what what are the games
that we could play there's going to be
three things I'm going to talk about
the first one is embarrassingly parallel
MCMC so can we MC MC seems to be
intrinsically a serial algorithm we we
interlace ample from these from this
transition colonel the theta T's the
whole theta T vector and we conceptually
would have to hold all the data in
memory on one machine or processor to do
these kind of operations and so that
would be a problem but there's now this
kind of increasing class of
embarrassingly parallel MCMC algorithms
which we've contributed quite a bit to
another game that we've been playing is
approximate Markov chain Monte Carlo
which is it's quite strange until
recently
what everyone has been doing religiously
in the community that works on these
problems is to define a Markov chain
Monte Carlo algorithm that has a Markov
transition kernel converging to exactly
this posterior distribution the exact
posterior distribution and so you want
to have no bias and so that seems to be
ridiculous and so by putting in a little
bit of bias like have an approximate
transition kernel instead of an exact
transition kernel you can actually maybe
get orders of magnitude speed-up and
then the question is can we
characterized theoretically that it
still converges and it maybe still
converges to within a small neighborhood
of the target posterior distribution and
I'm really quite excited about that we
have a paper under revision that annals
the statistics this really brilliant PhD
student of mine is now a Stein fellow at
Stanford was working on this he defined
a new concept called minimax and so you
could say well I have a broad class of
MCMC algorithms I have some
approximation error epsilon in the
transition kernel as I make epsilon
larger I can evaluate the transition
kernel faster and there's many settings
like this I'll describe in more detail
given time and so if that's true then if
you have a particular computational
budget say in ten minutes I want to get
the lowest possible Monte Carlo error
and some asked estimated posterior
summary of some functional F of theta
then I can define an optimal algorithm
under this continent in the worst case
scenario under the company
Mack's framework and so it's pretty cool
the third thing I'd like to talk about
given time is is data augmentation
algorithms particularly for kind of
discrete and imbalanced data discrete
data imbalanced because often what
people do in solving this problem it
might be hard to directly define a
Markov chain Monte Carlo algorithm for
this posterior and so sometimes what
people do is they introduce latent data
Z okay and so that you make the problem
kind of worse by you define some
posterior of Phi of theta given what
Stata and Z given Y and that's a bigger
space because now you have the joy
posterior of the parameters and some
latent data but it might be that in
introducing the latent data you've made
all the operations a lot easier now you
it's almost like an e/m algorithm
typesetting but for sampling so that's
extremely common to use data
augmentation algorithms they're used
just all the time and in Bayesian
inference okay and so so we've been
studying recently what happens with
these data augmentation algorithms in
terms of their computational efficiency
theoretically if you have really big
data problems okay and we have some
quite strong results on that but I'll
just kind of click off these three
topics and please interrupt me as we go
okay so embarrassingly parallel simply
so what we wanted to start out with is
okay well really what I'm most
interested in is so-called like big P
problems but let's start out with like
big n problems and so let's say the
likelihood of Y given theta can be
written as some sort of product from I
equals 1 to N of L of you could say Y i
given theta okay and so on so this is
reasonably broad but you can think of
this as the sample this is the sample
size so we have some likelihood that
takes a product form and so with just a
regression or generalized linear model
anything like that would fall in this
form but we can also allow the theta is
to include latent variables or random
effects and so that we have some sort of
conditional independence here and so
it's actually pretty broad yeah
just important the board flies over to
reveal more board okay that's cool yeah
look at that Wow
yeah but now it's on the wrong end okay
thank you
that wasn't a very deep question though
I know okay so I'm so if we have this
type of setting which is very quite
quite broad what happens is as the
sample size increases it becomes harder
and harder to do MCMC efficiently
because the often the per iteration
computational cost goes up in the sample
size okay and so what can we do what we
would like to be able to maybe put the
data on different machines and so if we
can define say K is the number of
machines or processors processors can we
do some sort of well let's say Y of J is
this sort of shard or chunk of data of
data on machine J okay and so well we
would like to just throw the data in
advance on different machines because
the data are enormous and to maybe run
em stamps in parallel in each machine
and then combine the results really
efficiently somehow okay that would be
embarrassing ly parallel MCMC and so so
we throw the data on different machines
we don't want to have a lot of
communication cost because that's going
to drag things down horribly there's
been some work in them using GPUs for
MCMC but it hasn't really been that
successful because the communication
cost and so what can we do well we could
imagine defining some subset posteriors
PI of theta given Y of J this is the
this is the the J sub set posterior
Syrio distribution okay and so that we
could define this guy as pi of theta and
then L of Y of J give given theta and
then we'll have our normalizing constant
but what we're going to do is we're
going to raise this guy to the power K
okay so we're going to just for
simplicity we won't have to do this we
will put equal sized chunks of the data
on different machines and then we're
going to define a kind of noisy
approximation to the full data posterior
using subsets and how we're going to do
that will take the prior distribution
and then we'll take the likelihood and
then we'll just replicate the data on
the JSON that J subset K times and so
that the effective sample size is now
the whole data sample size okay and so
what we do if we plotted what the the
subset posteriors look like the true
posterior might might be that's kind of
computationally intractable might look
like this okay well the subset
posteriors if we didn't do this raised
to the power K they would they would be
like flatter okay they might look like
that or something so if we raise to the
power K then we're going to have subset
posteriors that look like this and so
it's a type of stochastic approximation
which has been obviously enormous ly
popular and machine learning and other
contexts but but here we're doing a type
of stochastic approximation to the full
posterior distribution and so we have a
bunch of posterior distributions that
are noisy estimates of the target right
here so we're interested in this guy we
can't get him and so because it's
computationally intractable and so
instead we get some estimates of a bunch
of subsets posteriors that are provide
normal noisy approximations to the true
joint posterior and then maybe we can
take some appropriate notion a mean or
median of those those distributions and
that will give us a good approximation
of the of the true posterior
distribution okay and you could kind of
think of this in some sort of general
space call this M something and then
each point you could say would be a
probability measure corresponding to a
different one of these subsets
posteriors they're kind of noisy
approximations to the true posterior and
so this isn't some sort of Banach space
or something that's what each of these
points would be a posterior distribution
or posterior probability measure and we
would like to get an estimate of this
guy which corresponds to you know maybe
here maybe the truth is right here and
we get pretty close by taking some sort
of mean propria to mean in this space of
probability measures okay and if we
could do that efficiently we could
imagine running em simply and parallel
in each machine and then doing something
really efficient to get this this
estimated mean and then do inferences
based on that okay and when what we were
able to kind of work that out quite
beautifully I think and we have a kind
of series of methods the first one is
what we call wasp for Wasserstein
barycentre of subsets posteriors and so
you can call what's go define a
Wasserstein barycenter as some notion of
a mean in this set of probability
measures and so you know if we have the
central point we need to define some
sort of distance you know between
probability measures and the natural
distance is the Wasserstein distance
okay and if you use the Wasserstein to
distance and then you find the point
that minimizes the sum of those
Wasserstein two distances from a central
point to all of these different
different points in the space then
that's known as the Wasserstein
barycenter okay so in general the
watcher state and there's some wonderful
work by Tottori and our new to say and
other people on efficiently calculating
Wasserstein barry centers and we were
able to build on that actually and so
that if the if you use the sample so
that each one of these guys is atomic
which you would have if you ran MCMC for
each of these subsets posteriors you
would get something that looks like what
it looks like one over the number of m
sam c iterations of t equals 1 to 2 t
and you could put weights on the
and then that allows some sort of
weighted sampler sequential Monte Carlo
or something but have some sort of theta
of T kind of deal and so all of the
subsets posterior this would be the Jake
one say let's just say J okay and so
this would be our noisy Monte Carlo
estimate to the J subset posterior its
each of these points take this form then
we can actually solve for the
Wasserstein berry center using a sparse
linear program and so it's very fast and
so all we have to do we throw the data
on different machines we run em same
scene parallel on each machine with the
likelihood raised to a power which you
can easily do for example in stand which
is an automatic thing for for doing MC
MC and then you you just take the
results and then you just throw back the
samples to some central machine
installed the sparse linear program very
quickly and then you get an
approximation to the full data posterior
PI of hat of theta given Y which is also
going to have this kind of atomic form
to say PI T of Delta of theta T so it's
going to have this form so we sample in
parallel we feed back to the central
processor and we get this atomic
approximation the full data posterior
based on that we can do all the things
you usually do when I'm Sam C to get you
know point in interval estimates for any
functional the parameters that we care
about okay we yeah does this enjoy any
theoretical guarantees day if the data
are randomly spread on these machines
relative to the exact posterior yes yes
we have quite strong theory guarantees
on it from a variety of perspectives and
so we can say that this guy is actually
four for one we can say that there's
going to be some from a frequentist
perspective we can study the properties
of this guy and so we could well the
best parameter the clean your parametric
class a model say if you have a
parametric class of models there might
be some theta naught which which gives
you the parametric model and
class its closest in the coal-black live
to the indica lobular divergence to the
true data generator model the the true
posterior is going to be concentrating
around that point so are this guy is
also going to be concentrating around
that point at the same rate and we can
also get a handle on the distance
between the two and get nice balance on
that so it depends on both the between
this amazed at posterior and Wasserstein
distance and that's going to depend on K
and on em the the and our initial result
was not strong enough because I don't
want em m is the subset sample size but
I'd really like is that the subset
sample size is that the amount of data I
put in each machine I don't want that to
blow up because that would be cheating
because we want to blow up the number of
machines that's the appropriate
asymptotics and so we're able to get a
quite good result in that respect and
that we can we can grow the amount of
data on each machine very slowly felt
kind of like a log rate and then blow up
the number of machines and still get the
the distance event between the
approximation and the true posterior
vanishing okay and apuk like broad class
of models and so we weren't quite
satisfied with this because it's still
kind of complicated and so we actually
came up with something that i'm super
excited about which was just a couple
weeks ago accepted that biometrika which
is as follows and so let's see what do
we actually do this is some high
dimensional thing if you're doing
Bayesian inference in practice we have
these parameters what we're really
interested in functionals like f of j of
theta of the parameters like these might
be a bunch of coefficients in a logistic
regression model but we want to to get
the predictive probability of a1 the
patient has a disease given their
predictors and so that would be like a
one-dimensional functional okay so we
might be interested a bunch of
one-dimensional functional as almost
always you're doing inferences on the
posterior for one-dimensional
functionals so if that's true
there's an amazing result and so the
amazing result is that the Wasserstein
barycenter in the one dimensional case
can be calculated analytically and so
that we can actually do something
really cool in our algorithm and so
we're interested to like this is the
one-dimensional posterior if we're
interested in aligning one-dimensional
posterior our algorithm only has to do
the following we run MCMC and parallel
for each subset posterior okay we
calculate a percentile of interest for
any functional 1 dimensional function we
care about on each machine we feed that
back to the central machine and we
average that's all we do ok and then we
can get we can just build up at each
percentile we can build up this this
very theoretically very very strong
result theoretically approximation to
the true posterior using this really
trivial algorithm that we could do in
like Stan or something we on each
machine we run for our chunk of data
MCMC with the likelihood rates of that
power for any percentile of any
posterior one-dimensional posterior of
interest and we could we can actually
extend it to multivariate as well we we
calculate that percentile we just
feedback those percentiles as to the
central machine we average them okay and
we get very strong asymptotic and small
sample results on concentration bounds
on how close those are yeah are there
any questions about that we're pretty
excited about that because it's a very
broad class of algorithms for scaling up
MCMC and it has quite quite strong
theoretical guarantees unlike all of
Dave stuff you usually yeah it does yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'll give it to you no
questions okay okay so that's the 0.1 in
the talk and so I'm running out of time
to it so the so that's EPM CMC what we
were kind of playing with with that and
we're also working on ways where you can
divide up the variables we have a have
an approach that we have close to
submission where you have like millions
of variables and you can actually subset
the variables and then do computation
separately for those and get good
posterior proximation
but that's more it's not a general
result like this okay okay so the second
topic that I was going to go over with a
MCMC
okay just briefly okay so this is
approximate Markov chain Monte Carlo and
so usually what's the game so we have we
have some target posterior PI F theta
given Y and we define some sort of
transition colonel call it Kappa okay
and so that that transition colonel is
giving us samples theta T so we have a
sample theta t minus 1 we applied this
transition colonel we get a sample theta
T plus 1 and and then we have to have
that transition colonel obey the proper
Markov chain Monte Carlo rules or it's
not going to converge to the right thing
and there's all sorts of elaborate
algorithms trying to design k's that are
really good that can solve general
problems and converge quickly etc etc
yeah Ryan's done beautiful things in
that area for example okay so what what
occurred to us is that well what if we
instead relaxed this and made it like K
of Epsilon okay and so now now we have a
transition kernel this is the transition
kernel for the exact some sort of exact
Markov chain Monte Carlo algorithm this
is the transition kernel for an
approximate Markov chain Monte Carlo
algorithm maybe this transition kernel
is way faster to approximate what would
be one example one common example I
think Emily's worked on this for example
would be to use some sort of stochastic
approximation okay so this transition
kernel if we apply religous Markov chain
Monte Carlo and we use the full data
likelihood that might be too slow and so
we might be able to able to approximate
our transition kernel by taking a subset
of the data and then using some sort of
a set stochastic approximation and that
will give you an approximation to the
transition kernel based on the subset so
this might be a stochastic gradient
based it might be just based on the
subsets in other contexts okay and then
you can control epsilon based on the
size of the subsets so if the subset was
really small epsilon is going to be
really big okay
so what do we do what we'd like to know
how well how the hell do these behave
and so we have two assumptions
assumption one
the exact MCMC mixes well that's the the
dopey version of assumption one it mixes
well so we have some chain that we don't
have to ever run that we're going to
approximate that mixes well so it's
going to satisfy a dublin condition
which I won't get into the technical
details but it mixes well but we don't
have to ever ever have to run it an
assumption to is that K epsilon is close
to K okay a total variation distance
uniformly okay so these are the two
assumptions and so based on these two
assumptions we can show that well it's
going the Markov chain Monte Carlo
rhythm based on this guy is going to
converge to PI of epsilon theta Y okay
and that guy's close to PI of theta
given Y but more than that we were
interested in what are we actually using
Markov chain Monte Carlo for we're using
it to generate these samples theta T and
then based on those samples we're
calculating again these functionals of
the parameters so we want to calculate
some sub posterior summaries for these
functionals and so what do we want well
if we're running this thing T times we
want the money Carlo error in some
posterior summary for some functional of
interest to be small and we wanted to be
decreasing in clock time as fast as
possible so we run our MCMC algorithm
for five minutes
we would like the say the Monte Carlo
error in the posterior mean for one of
the parameters that we care about a lot
to be as small as possible okay what's
controlling the Monte Carlo error
there's two there's two parts the first
part is the asymptotic bias
the error our error and this guy based
on our approximate Markov chain Monte
Carlo is depending on the asymptotic
bias that's good asymptotic bias is
going to be increasing with epsilon the
second part is just the sort of pure
Monte Carlo error so that's going to be
decreasing at the usual rate in the
number of samples okay so the game here
is as epsilon increases we would like to
increase the number of samples we can
draw per unit clock time by F of epsilon
okay and so maybe as epsilon gets bigger
maybe s of epsilon will be ten or a
hundred a thousand and so we can
calculate we can generate a thousand
times as many samples in the same clock
time but those samples halves are giving
us some more asymptotic bias and so
there's going to be some sort of optimal
point that depends on the particular
computational budget you have and for a
particular computational budget there's
going to be an optimal and the loss
function for what you care about for
those two things there's going to be an
optimal choice of epsilon okay and we we
were able to study several classes of
algorithms that people use all the time
and and prove that these assumptions
hold and get actually practical insight
into their use and it was pretty
interesting actually and so what do we
what do we look at we looked at logistic
regression you know with I call it
stochastic approximation
like a mini bass bass logistic
regression and some people do these
things all the time and so oh I have
like a 10 million sample size and so I
can't run sampling for logistic
regression so I use sub samples okay and
so the subset sample size does that
become smaller epsilon becomes bigger
and we can get a perfect handle on that
okay we can show that these two
assumptions hold and something
interesting happens okay well I want to
do with just AG regression I have a
really big sample size and what's
optimal but what we found is that this
doesn't work very well because this the
epsilon is pretty damn big unless the
subset sample size is huge and if the
subset sample size is huge we don't get
much computational speed up and so maybe
in other context these mini-batch based
methods work well but in ours you could
kind of show that it doesn't work well
at all and so that was kind of a
surprising result that the theory kind
of exposed and then you could look at it
practically and say yeah that's true
actually these mini-batch things don't
don't work very well the other thing
that we looked at we looked at sort of
adaptive gaussian approximations
okay so you can imagine I'm running some
sort of MCMC algorithm if I have a
pretty big a lot of information about
certain my parameters maybe I'll just
use some Gaussian approximation that I
could do that cleverly maybe I can avoid
maybe I'm running a mixture model and I
have to like sample all of these mixture
component indices and there's like a
million of them well if I can look at
where that stuff comes into the
computation I can instead put in a
little Gaussian approximation to avoid
sampling all those things and so that
that actually works quite well
another thing we looked at was Gaussian
process models so for a GP model theta
is actually you know if function
function a regression function something
like that okay and so this was quite
interesting as well because there's a
lot of already a lot of a MCMC methods
that are ad hoc that people use where
you would say substitute in a low-rank
approximation when you're doing up
samtcy algorithms or something to reduce
the order and cube bottleneck that you
have in a Gaussian process model but our
conjecture is that most of these
algorithms actually don't satisfy the
assumptions and most of the algorithms
will if they converge it all converge to
something that's super far from the
target posterior maybe that's fine as
long as it works well but we could find
one class of algorithms that actually
works well and satisfies the conditions
and in this case you could like you
could get like for epsilon really small
you could get a huge computational
increase improvement and so this was a
big win unlike the stochastic
approximation the GP based model
approximations would say low-rank
approximation z'
you can have a very small epsilon and
still get a really big computational
advantage okay
so that was that was kind of cool that
you could get some tractability
theoretically in these okay so then my
remaining time five minutes I'll go to
the third topic and so the first is the
CPM CMC the second is approximate Markov
chain Monte Carlo the third is most
recent work that we've been doing on
data augmentation algorithms
da MCMC so people use this constantly
and so you you have pi if you care about
pi say it again Y but you do sampling
for pi theta Z given Y throwing in the Z
makes things a lot easier once you throw
in Z maybe the conditional for theta
given Z and Y is now just Gaussian or
something like that that's so there's
some very popular algorithms the one is
sometimes called Albert and cheb it's
for probit models you know so if you
have a like any sort of categorical data
model that's based on a probe a link
function this has been used probably
hundreds of thousands of times not cited
that much but it's used constantly
there's now a quite beautiful algorithm
we'll call it up for logistic regression
called polla gamma de dogma tation okay
and that that you works really well as
well we throw in some Layton Z's and now
everything's gone seeing again and we
can just apply wonderful things and it's
all beautiful
and and both of these algorithms have
been prone to have really nice mixing
properties like they're geometrically or
Ghatak and things like that but if if n
is huge what happens particularly if the
data are imbalanced okay and so which
often happens say well if the sample
size is really big how we started
working on this was actually a
computational advertising setting where
we wanted to look at your flow of users
between websites and n was enormous but
it's sort of rare to go to the client
website from a particular starting
website so the data really imbalanced so
that n is huge but most of things are
zeros mostly things I'm all but most of
the data are zero but n might be
hundreds of millions but most of the
data are zeros so that's true what we
could show is that we have a theoretical
paper showing that the mixing rate of
these algorithms as the sample size gets
big for badly and balanced data goes to
zero and so you can actually bound the
spectral
the Markov chain so that the mixing rate
goes to the zero and the square root of
the sample size are faster which is an
amazingly bad result for these models
and we were motivated by we are actually
trying to solve a computational problem
in that computational advertising
application and we could solve this time
per iteration but the mixing rate became
horrendous and so even in a very simple
problem if you look at the like kind of
lag the autocorrelation plotted so
you're looking at the correlation
between theta of T and theta T plus
delta it can be like this and this is
like a hundred and so you have to run
your MCMC algorithm for like a hundred
billion iterations to get a decent
number of samples okay
and so that was disturbing for for these
data augmentation algorithms because we
often have really big big imbalance data
and we have a bunch of Ecology
collaborations like this and we we were
having a hell of a time getting any sort
of MCMC algorithm to work and we tried
to convince them use variational but
they just thought that wouldn't work at
all so anyway the amount of time but the
the the thing we found is that you could
actually calibrate there is there is a
deep thing going on here theoretically
that we studied it theoretically we
could figure out what was going on and
so the reason the reason that these
algorithms fail or when they fail is
when there's a mismatch okay so what are
you doing in your MCMC algorithm you're
going to be updating the Thetas maybe in
different blocks given the Z's and then
the Z's given the Thetas and you're
going to kind of iterate through but
what if what if you think about what's
happening this and increases you know
your posterior distribution the PI of
theta given Y even if it's
one-dimensional it's going to be
increasing getting narrower and narrower
okay but what if the rate of
concentration of this posterior is not
the same as the rate of concentration of
PI of theta given zy
what if throwing ins the augmenting the
data fool the conditional posterior
converges faster it actually often
happens
so if this if this if these
concentration rates of this guy and this
guy are mismatched then in the as the
sample size gets bigger and bigger
you're going to get worse and worse
mixing and the algorithm is are going to
do disastrously and so this would be
true just broadly not we studied for
these algorithms and some other
algorithms but this is true broadly if
you have this mismatch you're screwed
okay and so what we did is we could
actually calibrate the data augmentation
algorithm to adjust for the mismatch and
if we calibrated then the the
autocorrelation plot went from that like
that just by applying a quite simple
calibration to the to the data
augmentation algorithm arrange matters
so that the conditional posterior
concentrated yes yes are you changing
the way here yeah so it's in some in
some specialized settings you could not
change the posterior but in general
you're going to change the posterior
slightly you could use that and just as
an approximate posterior sort of like a
variational approximation is approximate
posterior or you could use that as
candidates in a importance weighted or
use it in metropolis Hastings okay and
so all of those things work reasonably
well yeah just come up in like a ship
see as with some long and other
algorithms that are also sort of data on
vacation but for for the algorithm
itself or it is focused on where you
have sort of one absolute variant
purview now it'll come up in those other
cases as well
I think um and so it's really
interesting to study I mean we were just
starting in this case and they were like
oh this is going to happen in general
yeah if you have that miss a lot and
mismatch and so it would be really cool
to kind of apply to these other settings
as well okay I'm done
[Applause]
it's a good question about that yep okay
so the transition colonel is you know it
is a hassle to stimulate exactly if you
have this approximate budget that's long
assassin colonel
no that's that's your approximate
transition colonel and so so you have
you have the original transition kernel
k and then if you have error epsilon
approximation then you call that K of
epsilon and so you could actually call
it it technically it's like a class of
transition kernels that are within that
kind of all of the data right yeah there
you think would be enough to shift talk
about the expected parole you get that's
a good question yeah yeah yeah because
I'm because you don't have like you're
talking there's might not exact
correspondence between between the
subsets sample size and Epsilon
yeah we were you could do the expected
or we were looking at kind of like a cop
minimax framework where you can look at
the worst case transition kernel within
the ball kind of thing that it all plus
matters is the actual discrepancy
between K and k s+ wanted to display
English communicate
yeah I mean um so we had what would be
interested we had quite strong those
assumptions were reasonably strong and
so that you could you could match those
two things together and so because the K
because K epsilon was close to K and
under this other condition then you
could show that the stationary
distributions are close
[Applause]